>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, LOOK AWAY
FOR ONE MINUTE.
ONE MINUTE AND YOU GUYS, ALL
RIGHT, HAPPY FRIDAY.
WEARING MY GLASSES TONIGHT.
MAYBE WE'LL WIN AN EMMY.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THE
THINGS THAT PISSED ME OFF,
BESIDES THE LOOKS I GET WHEN I
BUY CLOTHES IN THE BOYS
DEPARTMENT.
NOT MY FAULT.
FIRST, BIDEN'S RATINGS ARE SO
FAR DOWN THE TOILET THEY COULD
WAVE HELLO TO CHRIS WALLACE.
IT'S SO BAD I HEAR BIDEN'S NEW
STRATEGIST IS ROTE 0 ROUTER.
WOW JUST A CHUCKLE.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD WORK.
NO WONDER HE'S ONCE AGAIN
TALKING UP STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS WHEN REALLY JOE
SHOULD BE ASKING FOR FORGIVENESS
NOT DOLING IT OUT.
FORGIVENESS FOR AFGHANISTAN, FOR
TANKING THE ECONOMY, FOR FARTING
IN FRONT OF THE ROYAL FAMILY.
THAT BOMB WAS SO RANK THE QUEEN
THOUGHT THE GERMANS WERE
BLITZING AGAIN.
>> Tyrus: DANG.
>> Jason: NOW THEY WANT TO
FORGIVE TEN GRAND, OR ROUGHLY
WHAT HUNTER PAID FOR A WEEKEND
OF HOOKERS.
OF COURSE THIS IS A HAIL MARY
PASS OR FOR THE GENDER CONFUSED,
A HAIL LARRY, KNOWN APPEAL TO
YOUNG VOTERS BEFORE THE MIDTERMS
WHICH SHOULD CRUSH THE DEMS LIKE
A DOZEN EGGS UNDER BRIAN
STELTER'S BOX SPRINGS.
DID I SAY VOTERS I MEANT
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS THE ONES TOO
DUMB TO REALIZE THEY'RE TRADING
THEIR FUTURE FOR A QUICK PAYOUT.
TAKING YOUR MONEY TO PAY A BRIBE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO HATE YOU TO
ELECT THE SAME FREAKS WHO
DEMONIZING DAILY.
IT'S A DEMOCRATIC BIRTHDAY PARTY
AND YOU'RE THE PINATA.
BUT LIKE GERALDO'S EX-WIFE,
THESE PEOPLE, THEY DON'T NEED
THE MONEY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jason: THIS ISN'T A FOOD
STAMP PROGRAM OR WELFARE, IT'S
TRANSFERRING MONEY FROM THE
WORKING CLASS TO THE WEALTHY AND
UPPER MIDDLE CLASS WHO VACATION
IN ASPEN WHILE RUNNING UP
COLLEGE DEBT.
AS REGULAR PEOPLE HAVE TO TAKE
SECOND JOBS.
OR, LIKE ME, WHO PAID FOR
COLLEGE BY MAKING DEPOSITS TO
SPERM BANKS.
SOME OF IT WAS MY OWN.
THINK OF ALL OF THE AOCs OF THE
WORLD.
THE WHINER WHO CLAIMS SHE CAN'T
LIVE OFF SIX FIGURES AS SHE
TOOLS AROUND IN A TESLA WITH HER
FRENCH BULLDOG.
I THINK THAT WAS HER DOG.
EITHER THAT OR HER FIANCEE.
.
>> Tyrus: OH.
>> Jason:
>> Greg: THEY CALL YOU RACE IT.
YOU CAN TELL WHICH TESLA IS
HERS, IT'S THE ONE DRAGGING AN
EXTENSION CORD.
BUT IT'S IMMORAL.
I SOUND LIKE PELOSI WHILE SHE'S
HANDING HER AMEX CARD TO HER
PLASTIC SURGEON.
AND IF YOUR BLOOD ISN'T BOILING
OVER THIS YOU MUST BE DEADER
THAN A FORMER CLINTON ASSOCIATE.
THINK OF ALL THOSE PEOPLE WHO
PAID OFF THEIR STUDENT LOANS.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S LYING PAINING A
HOOKER FOR SEX AND FINDING OUT
SHE'S BEEN GIVING IT AWAY TO
YOUR NEIGHBORS FOR FREE.
THAT'S WHY WE DIVORCED.
GETS WORSE.
HOUSE DEMS BLOCKED A FUND TO
DEFEND POLICE WHILE RECEIVING
TEN GRAND EACH TO BULK UP THEIR
HOME SECURITY.
IT'S THAT TEN GRAND AGAIN.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ASSUME EVERYONE
WILL CALL IT CHUMP CHANGE.
BUT WHO'S THE CHUMP?
IT'S US.
BECAUSE WE'RE PAYING FOR THE
SECURITY OF PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO
GRANT US THE SAME SAFETY.
DURING, THANKS TO THEM, THE
WORST CRIME WAVE IN MY LIFETIME.
WHAT'S THAT OLD SAYING, DON'T
PEE ON MY LEG AND TELL ME IT'S
RAINING.
THAT'S NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
HOW ABOUT DON'T TAKE A DUMP ON
MY HEAD AND TELL ME IT'S A MUD
SLIDE.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Tyrus: WHAT?
>> Jason: I'M DISGUSTING ALL OF
YOU.
BUT, REMEMBER, WHILE CITIES WERE
BURNING AND COPS WERE GETTING
KILLED, THEY SAID, LET'S HAVE
LESS POLICE.
NOW YOU SEE WHY THESE CROOKS GOT
INTO THE BUSINESS, SO THEY COULD
BE EXEMPT FROM THE PUNISHMENT
THEY ENACT ON OTHERS.
THEY CAN SCREW YOU BUT YOU CAN'T
SCREW THEM BACK.
AL CAPONE HAD NOTHING ON THESE
PEOPLE.
POLITICS ARE AS ORGANIZED AS
CRIME GETS.
AT LEAST THE GANG SISTERS DIDN'T
PRETEND TOING HELPING YOU WHILE
ROBBING YOU BLIND.
BUT THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
THEY CREATE LAWS FOR US AND NOT
THEM.
GAVIN NEWSOME MET FRIENDS FOR
LUNCH WHILE THE REST OF LA HAD
TO WRAP THEMSELVES UP LIKE
MUMMIES.
THE PRESIDENT'S SON HAS A LIFE
THAT WOULD MAKE CHARLIE SHEEN
BLUSH.
NANCY PELOSI'S HUSBAND STROLLED
AWAY FROM A DUI.
BUT I GUESS IF I WERE COMING
HOME TO NANCY I'D KNOCK BACK A
FEW SHOTS.
OF KEROSENE.
AND, FINALLY, A SENIOR FBI AGENT
ALLEGEDLY TRIED TO PAD THE
NUMBER OF DOMESTIC VIOLENT
EXTREMISM CASES.
MEANING, AS WE SUSPECTED THEY
WERE GAS LIGHTING US AND NOT IN
A FUN WAY THAT INVOLVED A TRIP
TOM TACO BELL AND FLICKING A BIG
LIGHTER AN HOUR LATER.
SO LIKE REAL RAGE THEY ENDED UP
HOPEFULLY BEING YOU.
NO SURPRISE THEY ALREADY
TARGETED PARENTS, TRUMPERS,
ANYWHERE NEAR THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6TH.
I'M SURPRISED THAT THEY HAVEN'T
GONE AFTER ME.
AND I'M GLAD THEY HAVEN'T.
I WOULD NOT SURVIVE PRISON.
I WOULD BE ONE OF THE PRIZES IN
A CARD GAME.
I'D BECOME SOMEONE'S BITCH
FASTER THAN COLBERT BECAME
BIDEN'S.
SO WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE GOOSE IS
GOOD FOR THE GANDER, SAID THE
GUY ZIPPING HIS FLY AS HE
APPROACHED A VERY SCARED GANDER.
I FEEL DIRTY.
>> Tyrus: YOU, TOO?
>> Jason: YES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY FEEL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTION
AND HOW WE HAVE TO PLAY THEIR
GAME ONCE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE.
IF THEY WANT TO BRIBE PEOPLE
WITH YOUR MONEY LET'S DO THE
SAME WITH THEIR MONEY GET ALL
THOSE GENDER STUDIES GRADS TO
PAY FOR YOUR PROJECTS.
HOW ABOUT NRA INSTRUCTION FOR
TEACHERS, FUND STUDENTS INSTEAD
OF THE SCHOOLS SO PEOPLE HAVE A
REAL CHOICE AT EDUCATION.
AND LET'S EMBRACE LOAN
FORGIVENESS BUT MAKE THE
OVERPAID COLLEGES REFUND THE
DOUGH.
DEFUND THE CRAP OUT OF THEM.
THEY HAVE IT COMING.
YOU SEND BILLY OFF TO HARVARD AT
73 GRAND A YEAR AND COMES HOME
FOR CHRISTMAS WITH A NEW PRONOUN
A PAIR OF HOME GROWN BOOBS AND
HATRED FOR AMERICA, I'M THINKING
YOU GOT A RAW DEAL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: POOR BILLY.
AS FOR CRIME, THEY APPLAUDED
INCOHERENT MOBS COMING TO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES HOME.
WHICH IS IRONIC WHEN THE
PRESIDENT, THEIR BIGGEST
CHEERLEADER CAN'T FIND HIS OWN.
MEANWHILE NEW YORK GOVERNOR SAID
TO DISRUPT LEE ZELDIN'S RALLIES.
WHAT IF THUGS MADE IT TO THE
NEIGHBORS OF PROGRESSIVE DAs AND
ANTI COP DEMS, JUST PUT FUNDS
TOWARDS HALF WAY HOUSES RIGHT
NEXT TO THEIRS.
MAKE ALVIN BRAGG OR GEORGE
GASCÓN HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT CRIME
LIKE YOU DO.
IT'S WORKING NOW WITH
IMMIGRATION, ALL THE PHONEY
SANCTUARY CITIES NOW MUST WALK
THE WALK.
IT'S TIME FOR A TASTE OF THEIR
WASHABILITY I MEAN, ISN'T THAT
HOW VACCINES WORK?
SO DROP YOUR PANTS AND BEND OVER
DEMOCRAT POLITICIANS.
THIS WON'T HURT VERY MUCH, I
PROMISE.
♪
>> PERIOD!
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
HE WORKED HIS WAY UP FROM BEAT
REPORTER BY SAVAGELY BEATING
OTHER REPORTERS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
WASHINGTON TIMES OPINION EDITOR
CHARLIE HURTS.
♪♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE THINKS IT'S A
TRIFLE TO CARRY TWO GLOCKS AND A
RIFLE, HOST OF LUXURY HUNTING
LODGES OF AMERICA ON FOX NATION,
KATIE PAVLICH!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
♪♪
>> Greg: HER CLASSMATES CALLED
HER TEACHER'S PET BECAUSE SHE
KEPT BITING EVERYONE
>> Kat: YEAH
>> Greg: FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND HE ONCE GAVE THE
TOOTH FAIRY A HERNIA, MY MASSIVE
SIDE KICK AND NWA WORLD CHAMPION
TYRUS
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: CHARLIE GREAT TO SEE
YOU AS ALWAYS.
>> Charlie: SAME TO YOU GREG
>> Greg: MISSED YOU
>> Charlie: I'M GOING TO LEAVE
THAT THERE
>> Greg: YOU COMFORTABLE.
>> Charlie: VERY COMFORTABLE
THANK YOU
>> Greg: LOT OF FACETS TO THAT
BRILLIANT MONOLOGUE.
CARE TO ADDRESS ANY ONE OF THEM.
>> Charlie: TRUTHFULLY I THINK
YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING HERE, A
BIG REASON WHY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS TALKING ABOUT
WANTING TO BAIL OUT STUDENT
LOANS IS BECAUSE THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY HAS BECOME THE PARTY OF
PRIVILEGED WHITE COLLEGE
EDUCATED PEOPLE AND IT'S ALL
PART OF A MUCH LARGER
REALIGNMENT THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THE POLITICAL PARTIES.
I THINK IT'S, PERSONALLY I THINK
IT'S A GOOD THING.
BUT THEY ARE TERRIFIED AND THERE
IS NO AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY
WOULDN'T PAY TO BUY OFF A NEW
SET OF VOTERS.
BUT THEY SHOULD BE -- YOU KNOW,
ANYBODY SHOULD BE AWARE THAT
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING WITH
HOW THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS,
FOR 40 YEARS, BEEN ON THIS
PROJECT TO BRING -- TO WOO
HISPANIC VOTERS, AND AS SOON AS
THEY FIND OUT THAT HISPANIC
VOTERS DON'T LIKE THEM, THEY'RE
LIKE, CALL IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD, LET'S BUILD THE WALL,
LET'S BE DONE.
SO ANYBODY THINKING ABOUT
GETTING INTO BED WITH THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE AWARE OF
THAT
>> Greg: YES.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE HUNTER
BIDEN.
WOW.
COMING BACK WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT POXES.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S TRUE.
>> Tyrus: HUNTER POX.
>> Jason: WE SHOULD DO A SEGMENT
CALLED POX NEWS.
I THINK WE DID
>> Kat: I THINK WE DID LIKE FOUR
OF THOSE
>> Greg: I THINK WE WERE THERE
FIRST.
KATIE TO CHARLIE'S POINT WE HAVE
MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER.
>> Katie: MURIEL BOWSER
>> Greg: TO COMPLAIN ABOUT TO
HAVE THE NATIONAL GUARD THERE
BECAUSE THEIR SANCTUARY CITY IS
LITERALLY NOW A SANCTUARY CITY.
>> Katie: HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
IS THERE A WAY WE CAN DO THIS
WITH OTHER ISSUES BECAUSE I
THINK THE HALF WAY HOUSE THING
IS THE SOLUTION.
>> Katie: THE FIRST THING I
WOULD SAY ON THE STUDENT LOAN
BAILOUT BE TERRIFIED OF THE 3-Ds
THE DERANGED WOKE WOMEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE MOST DANGEROUS WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY AND THEY
WILL SCREAM AT YOU IN YOUR
LULULEMON PANTS ESPECIALLY IF
YOU'RE A BLACK COP.
SO IT'S A PAYOFF FOR THEIR BASE.
SO YES THIS IS HAPPENING IN DC.
I REMEMBER WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WANTED TO SEND THE NATIONAL
GUARD TO THE ACTUAL BORDER AND
THE LEFT FREAKED OUT THAT IT WAS
XENOPHOBIC, RACIST AND NOW ALL
OF A SUDDEN PEOPLE START SHOWING
UP AT UNION STATION AND ALL THE
HOMELESS SHELTERS IN DC WHICH IS
ALSO A HUGE PROBLEM GETS FILLED
UP AND REALITY HITS THE MAYORS
IN THE FACE AND, OH, YOU MEAN
THERE ARE ONLY LIMITED RESOURCES
FOR A CERTAIN NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SO NOW ETHIOPIAN BUILD A TENT
CITY IN DC AND HAVE THE NATIONAL
GUARD PROCESS PEOPLE.
SO AGAIN THEY'RE BUILDING CASES
AND WILL BLAME IT ON REPUBLICANS
>> Greg: FLOSS CAGES.
>> Katie: THE WORST KIND
>> Greg: THOSE PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY COMING THERE TO WORK
AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
NATIONAL GUARD AGAIN PEOPLE
WORKING AS OPPOSED TO LIKE
DURING RIOTS DURING THOSE RIOTS
IN SEATTLE OR PORTLAND OREGON.
TYRUS WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THE
POINTS I WAS MAKEING? CARE TO
OFFER YOUR KEEN OBSERVATIONS?
>> Tyrus: I BELIEVE THE ORIGINAL
SAYING WAS DON'T BUSINESS DOWN
MY BACK AND TELL ME IT'S RAIN
AND YOU HAVE TURNED THAT INTO
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WILL EVER SAY THAT AGAIN
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> Tyrus: YEAH, I THINK YOU'VE
CHANGED THE GAME.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Tyrus: THAT WILL FOREVER BE
AN IMAGE.
THE ONLY GOOD NEWS IS RIGHT
BEFORE I COULD PROCESS THAT, YOU
GOT EVEN CREEPIER.
SO I'M STILL THINKING ABOUT THE
WHOLE SOMETIMES IT WAS MINE
COMMENT.
SO IN BETWEEN THE RIDICULOUSLY
INAPPROPRIATE CREEPY COMMENTS
YOU MADE SOME REALLY SOLID
POINTS
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Tyrus: IT'S JUST HARDED TO
SIFT THROUGH SOMETIMES
>> Greg: I LIKE TO GET PEOPLE TO
THINK AND PONDER.
>> Tyrus: YOU DID BUT WHEN
YOU'RE REGURGITATING AND
THINKING IT'S DIFFICULTED WHICH
REGURGITATING IS PRETTY GOOD
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE WOKE ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS SAY IT'S NOT A
PROBLEM WHEN YOU'RE UNEFFECTED
AND EVERYONE'S RACIST ANDSTEIN
PHOBIC UNTIL IT'S IN YOUR YARD
AND NOW IT'S IN YOUR YARD AND IF
I WAS GOVERNOR OF TEXAS OR
ARIZONA OR A BORDER STATE I
WOULD BE LIKE LET'S GET MORE
BUSES, LET'S GET MORE THINGS
GOING AND I WOULD START HAVING
BILLBOARDS, BEAUTIFUL
WASHINGTON, DC WHERE THE STREETS
ARE FULL OF JOBS AND MONEY AND
FREE HEALTHCARE AND I WOULD JUST
ARROWS POINTING THAT WAY AND I
WOULD JUST KEEP THEM GOING.
JUST KEEP THEM SENDING.
YOU KNOW?
>> Greg: I WOULD.
YOU KNOW, KAT, I WOULD LOVE TO
REPLACE EVERY POLITICIAN WITH A
MIGRANT WORKER
>> Kat: YES
>> Greg: TEN OF THEM.
WE WOULD GET SO MUCH MORE STUFF
DONE
>> Kat: I'M DOWN TO JUST TRY
ANYTHING AT THIS POINT.
TRY SOMETHING NEW
>> Greg: YES, THAT'S KIND OF
YOUR MO
>> Kat: YEAH.
I'M A CURIOUS PERSON
>> Greg: YOU ARE.
YOU'RE A CURIOUS KAT
>> Kat: THERE'S NOTHING WRONGING
WITH THAT EXCEPT ALL THE TIMES
IT'S GONE HORRIBLY WRONG.
>> Tyrus: NOT TO BRING UP
ANOTHER OLD SAYING BUT CURIOSITY
KILLED THE KAT
>> Kat: I AM STILL ALIVE SOME
HOUSE.
>> Tyrus: I'M WAITING FOR HIM TO
CHANGE THAT
>> Kat: IT IS AMAZING.
I DON'T KNOW, I THINK ONE THING
THEY COULD TRY IS MAYBE TRY NOT
SPENDING ALL THEIR TIME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT NEW THINGS TO
SPEND MONEY ON.
BUT THEY DON'T THINK OF THAT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND IF YOU'RE NOT ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS, WHERE DID I
MAYBE MESS UP HERE?
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE OBVIOUS
THAT YOU'RE CONTINUING TO HAVE
THE SAME PROBLEM OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD PRINT
MORE MONEY FOR STUDENT LOAN
DEBT.
THAT'S ABSURD.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE MORE
MONEY THAT GOES INTO IT, THE
COLLEGES HAVE NO REASON TO NOT
KEEP CHARGING MORE AND MORE AND
MORE AND MORE.
IT'S GOING TO KEEP GETTING WORSE
>> Greg: DIVISION TRIPLED THE
LAST THREE DECADES BECAUSE
NOBODY BOTHERED TO PUMP THE
BRAKES.
THAT ANALOGY
>> Charlie: I THINK IT WOULD BE
A TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTION TO THE
COUNTRY IF SOMEBODY DID PUT
TOGETHER A MASSIVE CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT TO GO AFTER THESE
UNIVERSITIES THAT TEACH NONSENSE
AND TEACH TOTAL BUMKISS IT
DOESN'T GET YOU ANYTHING IN THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF A JOB, AND
MAKE THEM PAY SOME OF IT
>> Greg: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THE
ONLY PEOPLE THAT DO CLASS ACTION
LAWSUITS ARE LIBERALS.
>> Charlie: I KNOW
>> Greg: CONSERVATIVES ARE TOO
BUSY CREATING RATHER THAN
TAKING.
>> Katie: THEY SHOULD TAX THE
ENDO YOUMENTS AND LET THEM BAIL
OUT THE HOMES.
THEY'RE HUGE AND THERE'S NO
INCENTIVES TO GET DRAWS WHEN
THEY LEAVE BECAUSE THERE'S NO
RETURN ON INVESTMENT AND THEN
THEY WANT THEM TO BAIL THEM OUT.
>> Tyrus: HOLD ON IN THE CAR
WASH BIDEN DOESN'T REMEMBER MUCH
BUT HE REMEMBERS NOT TO BRING
THIS INTO ACTION.
HE KEEPS SAYING NEXT MONTH
>> Kat: WHENEVER THINKS ARE
GOING BADLY HE'S LIKE HEY.
>> Tyrus: I K